hier werden keine lottozahlen gezogen
sondern einkommen verlost bedingungslose
grundeinkommen 1000 euro jeden monat für
ein ganzes jahr
einfach so ohne etwas dafür zu tun
klingt wie ein wunschtraum
der berliner verein meinen
grundeinkommen hat schon 53 verlost und
wieso beweisen dass es machbar ist
es mag utopisch klingen grundeinkommen
aber ich glaube es wird eine
wirtschaftliche notwendigkeit denn der
sozialstaat wie wir ihn heute haben wir
die antwort auf die industrialisierung
und jetzt haben wir über die
digitalisierung ganz neue
arbeitsverhältnisse viel prekärer fiel
temporär schneller in veränderung
dauerhafte erwerbs verhältnisse gibt es
nicht mehr und die einzige antwort
darauf geben kann die ich kenne ist das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen
eigentlich ist das was vereinsgründer
michael hohmeier vorschlägt eine
revolution menschen sollen grundsätzlich
finanziell abgesichert sein
egal ob bedürftig oder nicht jeder soll
ohne existenzangst und damit frei leben
können
insgesamt hat es bei allen menschen
positive effekte ohne dass sich darüber
werten wollen würde
wir haben drei leute die sich
selbstständig gemacht haben wir haben
nur einen einzigen der sich sein der
seinen job gekündigt hat im callcenter
der jetzt pädagogik studiert wer mehrere
menschen die eine weiterbildung
anstreben weil sie lust haben was neues
zu machen es verändert was im kopf es
verändert die haltung zum leben die
haltung zu besitzen die beziehungen die
ich führe wie ich andere menschen
betrachte das ich nicht mehr angst vor
ihnen habe oder oder konkurrenz zu ihm
stehen dass ihnen wirklich begegnen
viele wirtschaftsexperten sind dagegen
skeptisch
dominik enste forscht seit acht jahren
zum grundeinkommen
er findet die idee gut doch in der
realität sei sie nicht umsetzbar
denn würden wirklich alle weiterarbeiten
wenn sie auch so geld bekommen das
einkommen das geld das man bekommt
bezeichnen psychologen als hygienefaktor
das heißt das braucht man irgendwie dass
man auch akzeptiert dass man sich
anstrengen dass man leistung erbringt
dafür möchte man auch gerne
eine monetäre entlohnung haben wenn die
wechselt oder in diesem fall wenn ich
prinzip relativ groß grundeinkommen
bekommen ohne etwas zu leisten sind
natürlich die arbeitsmoral und vor allen
dingen wird es sicherlich am ende
schwieriger noch produkte und
dienstleistungen herzustellen
die eben nicht so viel spaß machen
kathrin klingt hat schon immer viel
gearbeitet
sie ist grafikerin und freiberuflerinnen
das geld ist knapp
vor einem halben jahr gewannen sie ein
grundeinkommen auf die faule haut gelegt
hat sie sich nicht durch das zusätzliche
geld hatte sie zeit für ein fernstudium
und ist heute dozentin für
gesundheitsmanagement das wird mein
leben dauerhaft verändern
ich konnte einfach planen und überlegen
wie investiere ich ihn was investiere
ich und raus aus dem alltagstrott also
sonst macht man einfach immer das
nächste projekt und das nächste was
ansteht
das war einfach neuer schritt in eine
neue richtung
der berliner verein finanziert die
grundeinkommen über spenden gesammelt
wird über eine internetplattform auch
kleinstbeträge von wenigen euro anmelden
und für die verlosung bewerben kann sich
jeder auch ohne spende im kleinen
funktioniert das aber wie soll ein
grundeinkommen für ein ganzes land
bezahlt werden
grundeinkommen braucht umverteilung
braucht möglicherweise auch höhere
steuern
viele sachen würden auch weggefallen
neben dem bürokratieaufwand zum beispiel
so etwas wie bafög alg1 alg2 elterngeld
kindergeld das könnte man streicht nun
durch ein grundeinkommen verhör wehr
setzen die finanzierung kann man mit 50
prozent konsumsteuer versuchen man kann
hoffen dass es keine schwarzarbeit gibt
also leute nicht versuchen nebenbei geld
zu verdienen sondern wirklich ihre
steuern bezahlen
man kann versuchen menschen davon
auszuschließen die nach deutschland
kommen
insofern zeigen aber alle studien die
mir vorliegen die ich kenne
dass es dauerhaft nicht finanzierbar ist
oder nur unter sehr typischen annahmen
sie glauben trotzdem an das
grundeinkommen mehr als 170.000 menschen
haben an der letzten verlosung
teilgenommen
neun von ihnen haben ein leben ohne
geldsorgen gewonnen
zumindest für ein jahr